they all start a path - and we'll start
actually how improve position of Bishops
your bishop
so here I have two examples okay I have
to reduce some of my preparation and
shows quicker so it was a game between
draws dolphins archive-it whom we
actually roll the textbook for all
Russian special chess schools the new
book it will be not published yet but it
will coming soon okay
black to move in this position what is
your idea what is your offer in this
position for black most of the players
start to thinking about how I can put d5
in this position
but actually in this position you cannot
push g5 without any problems your pawn
on e5 is hanyan yeah and white idea I
suppose his last move was like Knight c3
be one with idea c2 c4 block D 5 and
half tonight come on history and protect
everything you cannot play b5 you cannot
play d5 and your position will be
slightly worse but black can use
something they can use black squares how
I can do it
ninety-eight okay let's let's me explain
you if you can improve a position of
your pieces without the walls but
position of one of your piece it's much
better okay what is the 98 idea Bishop
g5 of5 that deck okay okay take a sense
yeah okay
Knight it but you have a better idea in
this position
Bishop g8 and Bishop d6 okay that's good
Bishop the eight absolute right idea so
white just spent the time to 93-91 with
idea c4 but black and replace bishop on
b6 and starting to attack on f2 square
it will be very very unpleasant for
white because white bishop situated on
b2 and doing nothing just protecting
Wyatt protecting white position if black
play plays d5 white can take and take on
a [ __ ] Bishop okay Bishop date
so the common idea okay hose defy but
Bishop d8 is right idea here
night a3 after c4 if I'd played c4 in
this position bishop comes on visit and
after black can play Knight g4 f 596 94
ok many may have many ideas so Bishop
the eighth night a3 Bishop d6 h3 knight
c6 Knight c4 and Bishop c5 could you
compare this position the last position
okay what happened after a 593 Queen c7
and after black already to play a look
of d8 and sound sound sound when I
default d5 ok blackest absolute 5 in
this position right even white not take
a control on d5 square could you compare
the last position and first position
black improve position of the bishop
easily and why why they have the time
why it was possible in position
that's my question could somebody
explain me why they have time in the mid
of the game not an opening to improve
position of our pieces sometimes it's
not a common common case have you idea
ok
okay it's a one-off idea but I would
like to hear about the control of the
center center of the board if you have
control in its center of the board
usually you can regroup our pieces don't
forget it if you have no control
okay just a player like Bishop d8 and
somewhere white can break through
immediately so to regroup our pieces to
improve position of our pieces usually
in the night of 10 position you need
good control on the center in this
position black has control okay next
position
same player with black pieces tserkov
and not the same opponent his opponent
was mark satan in this in this game so
black the move
to be shot advantage
as usual a bishop only sixty to eighty
twelve and the fighting in this system
usually is about everything around the
d5 square and in this case to your
pieces on e6 on f6 situated well
I've heard the memory okay we already
saw the previous example and the same
player play with back pieces this game
happened in six years after game drozdov
sykov and he knows already how he can
improve his bishop okay Bishop d8 well
bish of the 18th was his idea 96
is a very tempting I mean if white will
play in this position see for white is
absolutely fine okay right it has a big
advantage but Bishop gate is right move
do you have to show us the second one
okay I will give you two minutes
absolute right idea Queeny seven yes ah
sorry
no no 27 I also mention when you say
unbuckling b8 Queen date right so what
does the black idea if white will play
Queen III protecting on business
that's very easy queen III come on
who says
ethics bishop Quinn da 297 okay not so
big difference okay we just in the pawn
on d6 so white has retreated night on h4
next move you know our idea bring our
Bishop on sorry b5 okay I I have to
explain you after b5 what will happened
so you'd trade this very strong pawn on
e5 but after takes takes takes you open
the a file into pawn and a six become
very very weak white can okay even here
maybe after ob6
play b3 double and rooks on a file and
you have already two big phones on a six
and d6 became also weakness in this
position
No
see seven right who goes on to seven yo
you okay Bishop day goes on six seven
I've said it right so what was a black
idea now why we put a big Queen on the
8th and Bishop on seven the second main
idea in position okay it's a contains
additional idea but right now what is a
threat his main idea in such a position
T 5 D 5 D 5 D 5 is coming near White
House they care about this move if d 5
coming okay if black will play d5 we're
open to bishops and even they say if the
pawn on e5 so why white will be in big
trouble afterwards
white plate 93 his idea
okay maybe after d5 takes takes Bishop
takes d5 some way Bishop before trade
two bishops
and more dollars okay away
Rudy eight tween it to Quincy it now is
additional idea gherkin here we are
bringing with Bishop on the very very
strong yoga a7f to white didn't take
control on d5 square again because okay
well we cannot manage the play c2 c4 and
black has time just improve position of
black square Bishop brink with Bishop
from c7 on a 7 and start an attack on
with Jurgen are you okay - Bishop e8 h 3
bishop a 7
okay just show you what happened in the
game so could you imagine Bishop from e7
just jump on d4 in one moment yeah 91 d5
okay you can see it's very pitiful white
all night on Raymond okay
d5 looks very terrible Bishop a4 c3
Bishop c5 before now all white pieces
not on the place looking a three-night
Enosh to night on d1 we have 5 takes
takes and okay intermediate move Bishop
of 495 91
and okay in some moves white resign so I
show you only one idea okay how improve
the position of p7 bishops in in a night
operation according the Sequoias game
but I found it's fine idea
so I also learned something from from
him because I thought okay the main a
dd5 but bringing bishop on with Geoghan
at a 71 it's also possible okay let's
continue now I can explain more because
it will be my game it was the game in
Bundesliga I play against Mesa piano I
was a former Romanian players nowadays
he's a German player he were playing
Olympiad for German gym so you know come
on this position
I pray a bit of defense against him at
what at what moment at that moment it
was a theory a 97 h5 ok some way here ok
it's not a fan of our lectures b5 but a
strong move city is b5 if rook takes b5
r is move ok and black is ok he took
with pawn takes takes takes Bishop e5
sorry ok
break2 move in this position okay I
already show I explained you the
situation yeah when we are coming to
this position during the game so I have
to evaluate this position black looks
slightly worse in two reasons first
reason porn on h5 usually an end game
such bone is very strong just block the
two points on g7 on each six and ten
games every opponent games very bad for
black in this in this situation when
white porn situated on h5 I can remind
you the kurakin defense in kurakin
defense if you're coming in porn and
games or money right pieces and games
it's simple illusion for black such poor
knowledge 5 the second reason is pawn on
d5 which is blocked to other spawn on
Queen side a7 and c7 so what can I do if
I trade bishops only five Knight comes
only five on sistex attacking a 6-pound
somewhere ok it looks terrible for me
and I start to find the right decision
what I have to do in this position and I
prove position of my rook it's very
difficult to understand when you see the
first time the position in big
improvement my rock situated 28 but but
I need to trade this a pawn I have to
help with my ape seven-pole to trade on
a6 and afterward I will get counter play
it's a file so I played n-type router
and managers places oh wow such such a
move brocade
actually it's not so easy to find you in
the game but I found his idea idea a six
I would like to trade all pawns on the
queenside
and if why it takes on a succeed Bishop
I can take with night and attack h5
power and can take at night okay after
okay eight black equalize Israel so what
happened in the game room BC one
if white you play other move rook if you
want I can play Knight c3 takes takes
takes takes room d7 Bishop a5 now we
have the end games where the Bishop a
little bit stronger one night because we
have pawns on the boss both sides King
kept one Bishop e6 and black is okay
Arouca for coming somewhere okay for
take on a3 black is okay in this
position so Mississippi on a plate
rook BC one takes takes they extinct and
now a six black get a good counter play
and a file and white cannot get any
advantage 94 I have to play very precise
any case takes takes takes Knight take
h5 and draw White has to take on f7 I
will take on history so it will move
rook c8 e8 notice I am actually very
proud to this move so I managed to
equalize such a slightly worse position
in endgame again the strong opponent
okay so I would like to show you the
other stuff maybe in the middle I will
show you the combination to be more
interesting nowadays is famous idea but
at wet day when I played this game it
was an unknown how white can play in
this position it was my game against a
pozdneyev
in russian team championship in Sochi I
will say now the 2005
who is a more tactical player here who
can calculate elevations well okay who
thinks which is a tactical player okay
nice quails
and black no no sorry
it'll take a 6f text take on h6 I have
the options here okay and G takes f 6 IH
6 re-engage 8
okay that's exam this idea is sorry okay
Navi is night takes here the X check
okay who is playing qorikancha one okay
so I suppose I have to show you just
move 97 kg 7 yeah
oh nice nice okay if I shake
yes kink rich 7 okay
I suppose night exit 7 next move yeah ok
nice idea
no actually not
ok I like your idea but in other way
of course you have sacrificed all your
pieces will be remade yeah
but you have to find the right order
she'll screen when night first night
went green pesto Bischoff and cheating
is not allowed on this position now I
have not mentioned there are two K just
joke yeah okay Bishop day h6 so I can
play I can take in this case after
Bishop a statistics I can take on a five
I think not give you a chance to give me
mate no okay
night ages day 1 integer 7 right
g6 okay poor makes me sick
you have into the to this okay I will
give you a chance
twin g6o Bishop package 6 and I have a
special robot if you find the
combination Bishop takes it takes nice
yes King cage state and now is the most
difficult move here
please think a little bit more in this
position 95 95 85 95 95 I can go yeah
you have to find something the chicks
Bishop g7 check Wow Kim has to take on
g7 mm-hmm kink HP
and what is your friend Fred yeah
not kink kink or Kiki okay in 97 mate
yeah okay okay fate
Perpetua okay King Jade okay let's try
to think in with h6h six brilliant
brilliant and yeah brilliant
I will repeat these combinations because
he's exactly find what I did during the
game so I I took on g7 King takes rook
takes F 2 X is six Bishop h6 King h8 not
Queen your sacrifice extra extra piece
Bishop g7 check what is different if you
mean g6 rotate extra temp yeah takes yes
eight g5 rock f8 I'm sorry
when h6
then if keen if 98
yes okay this guy okay deserve the my
special reward for tactical skills yeah
okay
it's another my game against polygraphs
from Romania after the opening I have
got such good position with white pieces
black has to protect this a one poem and
I have no counter play at all so my
question how white can convert with
advantage to hope point
thank you thank you next time when I
come here you will be rekt oh I think
you know okay okay who knows
so first of all while you show you what
happened in the game I had a big time
advantage because I know this line and
my opponent thought what is a safe
position for black but I didn't fall so
and I decided to kill him immediately in
this position and I played g4 what was
looks absolutely gqo I improved my
position on inside left hd4 after a g4
kingi 824 twin b8f three kings is seven
okay
black has to wait I play Queen G's g6 25
so I thought his mistake because white
can be in the pawn rock take the seven
texts X takes check takes on the seven
and I hope I have been in position but
after Queen e3 I recognize I have
nothing because two pawns on the Queen
side just block history pawns and black
Queen is very active in this position on
history and everywhere black and give
the perpetual we need to Queen e1 I have
to protect my creating not after if I've
check takes okay
though I have to give you a batch of
being safe in 25
after I came back at my hotel I thought
white there's nothing even the computer
stages slightly advantage even the pawn
on the seven okay somewhere plus zero
point so Chi but like a human being
I found the one interesting plant for
one for Hawaii how white can improve the
position one of the piece of the board
and get a very good chance of swing
hmm
Lucas real okay five root B 5 okay it's
one of the possible plan here but but I
can defense with Kim G 8 Luke f8 and
after we fight through b8 just like
defense like Reese okay we cannot live
in the pond immediately on PC so what's
one of the plan yeah but I didn't see
how I can be in the poem cake in g8 Rock
if a trapeze you hear even if you play
for example let's say queen d4 I will
play some move I don't know in create
strange move rookie 5 let's pretend to
be 5 kinky 7 and I trapped your rook on
d6 okay you can play route d6 on d5 when
I can trade DC's
it's not a clear plan I mean you want to
take the poem but in some reason but I
can hold the position now write another
plan
okay my question is where white wants to
push the palms in which side to win the
game have you clear answer
now if used okay there's a Queens on the
board if you try to open the rear side
you cannot the switch on the other side
because you open your kink in this case
it's a remember kink with Queens okay
Queen
not brink a success okay it's possible
playing of course black has no contour
play at all but not to bring the final
success a space advantage of course good
chances and black has to wait but how
white can improve position of one of the
piece we all go and push phones on the
kingside I believe okay the main plan
because we have very strong porn on h5
and if we push somewhere g4f takes a
takes a 4G 5g six will win simple win
with strong position but in this case we
will open our kink if you push the phone
King h3 Wow okay so what is difference
King og - on h3 no you have to think a
little bit longer trip for your king
okay yes exactly yes yes yes absolute
right idea okay I suppose this guy
deserve my reward yeah I agree
so deep so deep thinking and he found
the right right away okay reward for
tactical skills rod for purchase on this
tangent here King Connie - and push the
pawns on the King side so I will show
you the right plan exactly only to not
only three not only be - on a - where is
the black has no checks 25
Luke a7 if Blake goes to the rook
endings it's not so good because white
can take pawn on e5 and win the game
injury so rue k7f4 King g8 and now
without any thinking okay you protect
everything your queen only five control
the c5 square root on the sixth row can
be three so it'll be seven break has to
wait in case if black will play in this
position Queen Queen c5 White has a very
interesting trick take take windey eight
if Queen f8 when rubgy Arab d8 as big
advantage on King h7 and rock the 8th
and made coming soon so rugby 7 kinky to
do 225 for first just protect be 5
square it's more safe --kinky --kinky -
we achieve our place here a to safe
place in Kiev 7 x3 now we are start the
pushing the bounds black Kings cannot go
on the Queen's Queen side because
somewhere
Queenie 5 okay let's say please move in
e5 they please
okay rook takes c6 every time you can
take on a 6th some tactic house idea
black teens has to stay on the King side
and waiting when the white pawns goes no
look up seven g5 ruku 725 come back and
through d2 and now black has absolute
hopeless because I would like to take on
a 6 or would you go and give a mate so
easy way to win just imagine where you
peace situated better than on g2 and
after push the pons okay unfortunately
we have to end our lecture and I I think
I tried my best in this lecture and try
to explain you how improve your pieces
during the normal game in a middle game
not an eye opening can open you know how
you can improve your piece just develop
your pieces on the best places so and it
was my pleasure to meet you here because
it was my first lecture in the United
States
thank you for a temp lecture